it's already been stated by the
authorities in public data facts and the
mood was to return to this country then
she is likely to face legal proceedings
on the basis of her attempts to
radicalize or recruit over social media
on the state the various statements that
she has made so she would be likely to
face legal proceedings but her family
has stated repeatedly that they would
prefer to be back in this country alive
rather than to die in Syria and do you
think that that is the appropriate way
of dealing with these very young women
girls some of them who try to go out to
join is to effectively criminalizing
there seems to be a hysterical and new
jerk response to many of the young
females were 15 16 17 who do travel out
to seduced by the propaganda of Isis who
are sold a package which when they
arrive in Syria in Iraq many of them I
believe have their illusions and dreams
shattered rapidly who are then married
off to jihadist fighters and there's a
former grooming that take place I think
it's essential that this country meets
its moral and international obligations
and if those individuals we would prefer
to have them back in this country rather
than engaging in atrocities or rather
than engaging in the radicalization of
others and and I think essentia taller
this is I as a member of the community
has grown increasingly tired of the
belief that what it takes to stop young
people joining Isis is having men in
their 50s and 60s and older standing up
repeatedly on TV with long beards and
saying Islam is a religion of peace and
do not join Isis that doesn't clearly
doesn't work with these young people
what we actually need is those people
who have been recruited by Isis those
people who've had their dreams and
illusions shattered and who have seen
the barbarism and the atrocities who
when they come back to this country if
they wish to renew their social contract
then they should be used to D radicalize
and tell these young people what
actually is the truth because quite
clearly what we're doing at the moment
what the community is doing and what the
government's doing is it is it working
these are girls from Muslim backgrounds
but you think what we're really seeing
here is sexual grooming is that right
well to a certain extent with many of
the younger females I believe that there
is sexual grooming I mean if you replace
the word Isis with Jimmy Savile for
instance and you had 15 and 16 year olds
who will be spoken to over the internet
social media for a number of months by a
male who then seeks to have them leave
their family and move to another country
and then nipped across the border and
married off to some guy who's you know
in their 20s or 30s what else could we
call it other than abduction and
grooming quite clearly they get their
claws into these people's minds and the
first step is to break them off from
their family to hide these issues from
their family and then wants to get out
there it's far too late I know many have
said that these are straight a students
they're lovely people they're young
people you know they're bubbly they were
well liked in the school that's really
got nothing to do with it we should
remember the fact that they are
extremely young people and they don't
have the experience of light like let's
say somebody in their 30s who somebody
tries to you know recruit and preach
propaganda to might well not take to but
somebody you know in their teens can be
seduced and we've had cults it's been
described as a death cult Isis quite
rightly but cults have existed in the
past this is nothing new they existed in
the 70s and the 80s and they operate on
the same process except that Isis is
heavily funded has a budget I believe in
the region of the CIA set of 1.3 billion
dollars a year which is used to spread
propaganda and a very so you know slick
videos that are put out and images that
are put out there are well in advance of
what al-qaeda perhaps did some 10 years
ago mr. Anwar thank you very much indeed
for joining us